she believed in getting paid to wait she
would never own
anything that didn't send a check to her
each month or each quarter
and she would live off those
distributions but if it didn't pay you
money she didn't get it she didn't
consider an investment she'd call it a
speculation
bitcoin is going to break into two asset
classes blood coin from china
and clean coin
[Music]
i i know that the people are posited in
certain types on these shows
and i always never find you as the
grinch i find you as the sensible guy
some of the some of these people listen
i i love dreamers but some of these
people
it looks dangerous to me when they're
gonna push more chips in
and i think at some point somebody
should step in and say listen you gotta
as you say take it out back and shoot it
because this
could ruin your life so i never find you
mean i just find you the quintessential
pragmatist
well i think that's kind words because
um
you're right my mother taught me years
ago if you always tell the truth you
never have to remember
what you said but you know the thing
about business is binary either you make
money you lose it you see a really bad
idea and you start to feel sorry for the
person mortgaging their home
you know it's going to zero and frankly
you know
if if you can't get through me in the
shark tank where the real world gets a
hold of you it's going to chew you up
and spit you out
so you know i really care about their
money not so much their feelings and
that may sound cruel but in the end of
the day
it's lucky they met me that's what i
think
yeah your interaction with them when
they come into the shark tank for god's
sakes people are so
whiny these days and oftentimes not the
people who come into the tank they seem
to be intrepid
to some degree but the people the
protectorate out there
talks about the nicety of it i i never
get that there if you
if they met you in regular life and had
a problem
i i can see what picture boxes as far as
when you get emotional i think you'd
help them
this this is an exchange of information
here they've got a product you have an
expertise on gleaning whether products
are viable or not
and i always think god he owes them his
honesty what good do they do to
take them further down the road yeah i
mean i agree with you but you know you
got to remember something about shark
tank it's been around now for 12 years
shooting its 13th season it's created
dozens of multi-millionaires sold
billions of dollars worth of product
it doesn't you know lightning doesn't
strike every time but every once in a
while you get this incredible idea a
fantastic concept
and then you've got the benefit of
millions of eyeballs through syndication
eight minutes of prime time television i
mean
your customer acquisition costs go to
zero and you make a ton of money it's
not uncommon to sell five million
dollars
worth of a product that's seen on shark
tank that same night
that happens all the time no it is like
a visual ipo or the road show or
something and when the guy comes in with
the smiley face that cleans the glass on
at least he's got something i just
finished that book about that more on
adam newman and i thought
you know it's like gertrude stein said
at the end of the day there's no
there there i i wha what was happening
what makes that any more viable than a
squatty potty
indeed the squatty putty put you in an
angle to pass extra men and all it did
with adam newman was he was
the [ __ ] was coming out of his mouth for
god's sakes
well i've got one for you if you want to
go down that path check this out
this is a cat dna kit now you're going
to pay me 29
and i'm going to tell you when kitty's
going to bite the big one or you could
spend a lot less and just buy a new
kitty
but hey i'm not a cat guy you know what
i mean i don't like cats but i love cash
flow
this thing makes a ton of money because
there's 110 million cats in america and
people want to know where their kitty
came from
and i know after you send me back the
data when kitty's checking out a dodge
forever
and you need a new kitty test kit it's
this is a fantastic business listen
forget the litter each cat has nine
lives the up sale is to get one kit for
each of the nine lives
exactly there you go brother that's like
you gotta push who would have ever
thought of that that's the whole point
you know somebody walks to the door and
shark tank
cat dna kit i think that's nuts and then
she gave me your numbers they said not
so nuts
i'm in listen i i get the whole
potpourri of the show i'm
well i'm a little incredulous that uh
cuban has started to believe that he's a
potentate
that that's the aspect of the show i
don't get as much anymore
but i get that some of these are light
things you get the touching one
that cutting board with a fireman that's
still one of the sweetest moments i've
seen in the last
is what a what a living testimony to the
goodness of a man that those three kids
come in like that it wiped me out
but there are other people and like i
said i think you do them a service
warning them off certain things because
it does get dangerous you know kevin
as i watch this recent acquisition of
the steppenful
in an odd way it made me think of uh
ellsworth too he
where he said i play the stock mark of
the human spirit
right now i'm selling short
unfortunately in the times we live
there seems to be great fortune to be
made uh
playing the uh you know we're almost
like
uh chaos hysterics or something
i i always think oh let this covet thing
go away can we move on can we just push
through this and eventually
and now i can see some people are
trenching in for the long run we're
going to start opening doors with our
feet
and eventually you'll have to get the
carpal tunnel
thing for shaking with your elbows
there's a whole bunch of streams coming
off this i didn't see
you're right but i'll tell you that
product is going to be huge because
people over the last year have come to
the conclusion that if you touch
a public door handle in a latrine
somewhere
you are going to die and so the only way
to save your life
is to use your shoe to open the door and
thank goodness i'm there for you
another opportunity to help you survive
in a world just
teeming with disease and look far for me
to say the product's not good it's
selling by the millions of dollars
because people just do not want to touch
that handle
and nor should they dennis that's what i
love about shark tank
i love your i love your glenn gary side
because indeed coffee is for closers
it's just not
they'll tell you the coffee is bad for
you we live in times where i think we've
just
emotional hemophilia runs rampant across
the land we're talking to kevin o'leary
and of course you know him from shark
tank he also is a
chief sommelier about larry fine wines
and he's really
picked this business up and ran with it
was it
was it your pallet early or was it your
your
uh portfolio that first brought you to
wines i i assumed back then you liked
wine before you were able to invest
right
well my dad my stepdad lives in
switzerland and he's really
was was into wines when i was a teenager
and he started teaching me about the
different varietals
burgundy's bordeaux's the drc region the
italians you know
the cabernet moscato all of these
different uh
you know i just learned in europe people
aren't as uptight you know kids drink
wine watered down with water when
they're seven years old
that's just how they do it in
switzerland and so you learn early on
and i learned how to blend wine and so
you know i finally
when i was very fortunate i started
investing in
vineyards and the best way to turn
yourself into a poor guy is to invest in
the wine business because there's three
tiers of distribution
and then along came the laws changing
about six years ago where you can ship
from your winery in california
to 42 states direct and that changed
everything for me because the whole
shark tank thing i became the wine guy
and now i could go online and say look
i've selected
you know these 12 wines for you that
i've landed myself i've won five awards
or 10 awards because i have
and we started selling direct and that
business is huge today
i ship 150 000 cases a year
wow and fun too and what a perfect
staging ground you had parentally
with your stepdad and your mom who
sounds like she was a
fiduciary wizard and your stepfather
what an eclectic trip
by the way did you spend time in
ethiopia when emperor selassie was still
alive or what what age were you there i
actually met haley selassie i met his
lions i lived in addis ababa
i went to where he kept those lines and
he became a deity for the rastafarians
as you remember i'm he was a he was a
a man a short man of stature but i met
him personally
i met paul pott i met see a nuke i met
them all because we were living in those
countries imagine paul pott that crazy
you know what uh and folks what kevin
says there about celestia is always one
of the most mind-boggling boggling
things to me he went to jamaica
he was such an exemplary man he was gave
off such a fine
vibe that the rastafarians made him
their
their god in essence do they think of
him as their christ or do they know it's
a man
who walks amongst them what i never
understood that completely
i don't think they understand i think
they really loved him a lot and he just
became part of their culture and they
adopted him and it's a remarkable
outcome
but when you talk to people you're dead
on they love that guy he was
he was a kind-hearted leader you don't
get those anymore
and he was one of the last of the of
that kind of leader and the people in
ethiopia loved him too he was
he was very well respected so your
father stepfather gives you an ian
fleming sort of cachet
and then your mother i love the advice
earlier it's one of the truest things
you can say to a kid who wants to go
through life
juggling all these balls trying to
figure out which story you told who
you tell the truth and you your head
hits the pillow and you can sleep
your mother was also very smart in
economic affairs right
yeah she actually um sort of gave me my
investment philosophy she used to take
20
of her salary when she was in you know
her
early 20s and put it into the stock
market dividend-paying stocks
she had that portfolio secret portfolio
from both of her husbands
she was married twice and you can't do
that today but she pulled it off in
those days in the in the late 50s
and when she died i got a call from the
executor i was the older brother
and he said you got to come down here
your mother died a really wealthy woman
so this portfolio of telco bonds
and s p stocks for 55 years
i always wondered how she had all this
money around all the time and
and that's what it was and so i went and
looked at that and said i'm going to do
the same thing and you stash a little
bit away of what you make
each each week when i was young i was
doing that put it in the market
an average goes up about 78 a year and
you just leave it alone
magic happens that's how it works
didn't that grain silo-sized cookie jar
she had in the kitchen hit you to
something my friend did you not
did you not read that tea leaf tell me
what uh as a
having a mom who put it into telco what
would she make of
uh bitcoin today i'm trying to think if
she would
i see that you're pushing in now after
some skepticism what would she make of
it
she believed in getting paid to wait she
would never own
anything that didn't send a check to her
each month or each quarter
and she would live off those
distributions but if it didn't pay you
money she didn't get it she didn't
consider an investment she'd call it a
speculation
so that's why she had bonds and big fat
juicy dividend paying stocks
it's not a bad strategy she would have
never done the bitcoin thing she'd say
what the hell is this
where's my check you know it's that kind
of thing well you know i was skeptical
too and i was trying to find some sort
of strunk and white primer to understand
it a little so i read ben mesrick's book
about bitcoin billionaires
i still don't understand it completely
but i see where you've said
that you will only invest in bitcoin
where it comes from for lack of a better
word a a
fair place like fair trade practices or
something like that
but the very birth of bitcoin i think
right after nakamoto births set
isn't it used by guys on the the dark
web the silk road
initially isn't it sort of scarface
illegal tender or something isn't that
its birth
64 of coin mine comes from china and
there's a lot of compliance issues with
china first of all
many of them burn coal which you know
i'm talking from the institutional
perspective what happened to me was i
said okay i'm gonna go three percent
waiting
and then i started getting phone calls
all over the from all these institutions
that i work with because i've
got other businesses that service
institutional financial services
and they called me up and said hey wait
a second uh where's this coin coming
from i said who cares
they said we care we care we don't want
to invest in anything that's mined in
china
because of human rights issues because
they're burning coal and
you know i had to listen i so i started
looking at it and said well i got to
find miners
that are doing this on a compliant basis
that aren't you know burning coal and
sticking into the atmosphere
because i've got 10 000 employees in my
supply chain and all the companies and
they're all into sustainability
so they had questions too and i've
discovered that there's a whole market
emerging pretty fast about people are
saying i want bitcoin but i want it to
be mine sustainably
and i have to go mine that myself so i'm
i'm investing in a whole bunch of miners
now
that i just get my coin direct it's
virgin i know where it came from
and they make it for me that's the best
way to do it and other institutions want
to do the same thing
bitcoin is going to break into two asset
classes blood coin from china
and clean coin and they're going to
trade at a different price one day
uh just like the blood diamonds folks if
you want to put it in layman's turmeric
and i am the quintessential layman but
that is going to become a very big part
of
investing in the future is finding out
what the
the the the first origins of it are
because
uh let's face fact kids are in the
fairness business right away
and they're they're not going to get on
board with people who are gaming people
early on in the process
for their uh their worth i want to talk
to them about kids now when i was a kid
it was all about
the house and that all that's changing
uh we've got a good brain to pick here a
big one
uh as i said along with josh braun two
of my favorite
and i am a layman you can watch both
these guys
and up your game a little it's like
playing tennis with somebody who doesn't
leave you in the dust but plays really
well
and makes you play a little better um
you know kevin when i was
the kids today that's one thing i
learned from the adam newman book is
i i don't know if it's a naivete or an
urge to do
well or some some sort of dangerous
altruism i do believe altruism can lead
the obsolescence at some point
if you don't pretend your own garden at
some point but
i i do see that they're less interested
than i was
when i was young and i didn't feel like
an outlier in making a killing
they're more interested in being
comfortable and then
helping everybody else that's a big
tectonic shift isn't it it is
there there is a new movement afoot
about sustainability about caring about
your neighbor i mean
maybe this is post pandemic kindness i
don't know but it
i i see it in a lot of the people that
that work for me in various companies
and and i've noticed something really
interesting
the companies that are successful that
i've i've invested you know in over 50
and
probably right now 34 of those 50
look like they're going to do very very
well and those are the ones that have a
mission
they're very driven by something they
really care about
and they have a sustainability theme so
the customers
favor their products and services not
from some marketing scam because that
use
you know i used to think the green thing
buy this product and we'll plant a tree
i thought that was a marketing scam
it's not there's a whole bunch of
consumers today that
really care so if you're polluting and
you're making your stuff out of plastic
bottles and shipping it they don't want
your product anymore they want
people to give a damn about the things
they care about and this has become
a really interesting change and and i
think unique in some ways because
usually you have to be a skeptic but
when you see products i'll give you an
example this is another one
i've got dozens of these this is a
company that takes
cleaning fluids and crystallizes them
into this little tablet like an
alka-seltzer
you get a sustainable bottle you use
over and over again you drop it inside
with water
bingo that's your toilet cleaner there's
no plastic bottle to throw out
these guys came on shark tank and i said
what the hell is that he said well this
is our patent we can take any cleaning
fluid crystallize it
and we ship this direct to consumers and
we're going to get rid of 85
billion plastic bottles wow
so i invested in them they did 80
million bucks in the first 24 months in
business i mean
they're exploding because because people
give a you know they care
they they care and that's the new the
new model of sustainability i'm
i'm in a joint venture with comcast on
that one and i think we're going to make
a ton of money on it
you know what kevin i i know after
watching you for years that uh
well two things uh and that was one
other thing about the
the stepping pole that fascinated me you
didn't ask for a little
stipend on each sail you just i could
tell that
the blood was in the water for you on
that one when you just went down to six
from eight and you didn't ask for a per
sale piece of it like you know that
product is going to sell you
know when that thing airs every guy and
his dog wants one
and that's exactly what happened people
are really freaked out after that year
we've never had anything like this
and now no i'm not touching that door
handle never
ain't gonna happen and the thing about
that product was
they designed it so you didn't scuff
your shoe because most of them have that
little
you know the teeth on so you stick your
shoe on it and you scratch your leather
it's stupid not these guys
they figured that out smart i think i
i think the uh good-heartedness moving
into the marketplace is going to
eventually skew
customer acquisition costs or do you
think it'll remain a constant i know
that's important to you
if the word gets out on the street
amongst young people that you're doing
the right thing
making a buck but not being piggish
about it i i don't think you have to
spend as much to procure them i think
they'll come to you if they feel you're
doing the right thing
right yeah you're right because of
social media what happened is
now because of the immense power of the
direct communication with your customers
that these successful companies are
utilizing because they grew up with it
they understand how to tell their story
and people smell [ __ ] a mile away
now you can't
scam them anymore so if you're a big
company you're trying to bs about
sustainability they don't believe you in
the first place which is why all these
new brands
are merging so quickly you know that
they're basically saying look i'm not a
scammer this is exactly what i'm doing
and i do care about sustainability and
i've done this or that
and it's an honest dialogue you know it
really really makes a difference i'm
amazed i'm amazed you know
it just i keep looking at these examples
here's another one
here's a company that that makes
greeting cards
love pop greeting cards all right that's
a grading card beautiful
they went from retail during the
pandemic and shifted
79 of their business direct to consumer
by telling their story saying
you got to buy direct from us we're
going to go out of business if you like
our stuff and you send it to your
mother and whatever and those that
direct communication
boom it just exploded and they had
millions of people
ordering their cards i mean i'm all i'm
amazed at the power of television the
power of social media
the power of podcasting all of these
direct to consumer
vehicles have changed how business is
emerged in america and if you're not hip
to that and you're not doing it
you're going to zero that's what's going
to happen you're dead
you're dead well there was one thing
about the newman book that i read that
did make sense to me
as you said those guys i think as i've
read
they now realize they don't need the
office space anymore it's almost like
brick and mortar is going uh the way the
cabbage patch
kids or something but that's going to be
a big
challenge in the future isn't it the
malls
stuff like that places you have to go to
that have many door knobs and
it just seems so much easier to do it
from home right i think
right now it looks like i've got some
data just my own companies out of those
10
000 supply chain people about 15 percent
have no
interest in coming back to the office
they were the ones that worked in
compliance accounting
and logistics they they worked in those
little cubicles
they don't want that anymore they have
no interest in working in a cubicle so
they're not coming back and if i can't
accommodate them
they're going to work for somebody else
that's going to become a feature of
employment
they're raising their kids or in the
suburbs they're taking care of elderly
parents
whatever it is they've they know with
certainty they can run their business
remotely like we're talking right now
all this technology is empowered this
digital pivot
and frankly i think the economy is more
efficient that way why do you have to
fly all over the place to do business
anymore why can't you just do a zoom
call
work out a deal and you know fulfill it
it's it's so much easier
than staying in a crappy motel eating
bad food and flying all over the place
and
particularly in the winter when travel
sucks who knows willie lohman might
still be alive if we had zoom back then
you know i'm fascinated by entrepreneurs
and i always think that part of it is uh
well they dwell in the ether but also
part of it is
i think when they see something that's
about to happen
they realize they want to step through
that stargate
as quickly as possible i used to golf
with richard rainwater up here
and he was just an awesox guy when we
golf but he you know i knew he was a
wizard so i'd pick his brain
and he told me he was golfing once in
the crescent dot in dallas and a guy
pulled a phone at that was the size of a
walkie-talkie from
the old tv show combat and he said
what's that and the guy said it's a
phone
richard raynor said we're on like the
third hole i said it's a what
he said it's a phone he's sorry i said i
can't finish the round
he went back to the clubhouse called sid
bass and said
we got to liquidate and push everything
there's a phone out there now that you
carry with you
so i i think at some point is it not an
entrepreneur
uh well you've got to glean it first
then you have to act
very very quickly right kevin yeah
because it's not just domestic
competition there's a guy in shanghai or
mumbai
that wants to kick your ass and is
willing to work 25 hours a day to do it
i mean that i see that all the time now
i mean great ideas here
or you know any great idea anywhere can
hit the market in a matter of weeks
if and if you're not first you're going
to have and even if you are you're going
to have competitors that come after you
it really is a global competition
there's no question about that and i
watch it happen all the time so
i'm in the same boat when i see
something i like i invest in it and try
and blow it up really quickly the best
way to defend yourself is to get market
share
even if you don't have a proprietary
technology if you got market share
that's hard to emulate hard to get so
you know the people that bring
products out first tend to re like the
snuggie remember the snuggie
there's a million knockoffs of the
snuggie but the snuggie made all the
money and everybody else
tried to beat them it's too late you
know the the one i've watched over the
years
and i can't even remember the episode i
don't go back and watch
but the guy who had the uh the ring
it's such a brilliant such a part of the
uh americana now i'm trying to think
how did how did he go through and not
get money was it what was his ask
what what fell apart that evening he
asked for six hundred thousand dollars
now a friend of mine is named jamie he
works
directly directly for bezos at amazon
now and we we we do a
a a lunch every year on nantucket
on july 4th where we invite our families
together it's a lot of fun he's a great
guy
it's sort of a ritual we do each year
but he asked for six hundred thousand
dollars he had no product it was just a
prototype and he wanted it in equity i
said i'll give you the 600
but i want it in debt and i want a
little taste i want to wet my beak and
two and a half percent
options in your company i know i'm going
to get diluted into oblivion because
you're going to issue so much stock
but the debt's the debt you're going to
have to pay me back at a reasonable rate
i think i quoted him
9 or something for 5 years i mean that's
a good deal
and he said never i can go raise money
easily i don't need your debt i don't
want to be
you know be underneath a cap table that
i owe you six hundred thousand dollars
and had i done that deal not that i ever
cried over spilt milk i think i would
have made about 800 million dollars
you know some guys come in though i i i
think that
you know there are guys who come in who
piss me off who you know they're
they're there it's it's it's it's pound
wise
pennywise pound foolish they come in to
be on a tv show
and get it out there and they're not
taking uh you know they're not
giving the proper cachet to a shark it's
such a big
thing now it's a two of them in your
corner
can really help you so the guys who come
in just to get on tv
i don't think he was like that i i
almost think in retrospect
he would have he would have dealt if if
he heard the right thing right yeah it's
it's true but i
i have a different view that was years
ago today i know my value as an investor
you know and so when people make me
offers and say well my
last round was at a billion dollar
pre-money i said i don't care about any
of that
there's only one mr wonderful i'm going
to make you an offer i'm not going to
negotiate with myself
if you like it take it if you don't
don't because there's lots of other
people are making the offers but i set
my own valuation based on my own
value and some people hit the bid and
some people don't
but i never go by what they think their
business is worth i got a whole team of
guys and i say
on top of that i want the mr wonderful
discount
because when i become an investor
millions of people hear about it
and i deserve to be paid for that i'm
not free i'm not a cheap date
but i'm happy to work with you and at
the end of the day it works out 50
of the time but i never compete with
myself you know you look back and i'll
tell you who's good at their job as
burnett
because geez i i i wonder if he sat in
the casting room
because i look at the mix there and i
just think wow somebody was
super smart here the one guy early on
was a little too close
to lori and gotti was a sweat act about
pennies he
had the guy in the second chair over i
knew he had to go but you look at some
of these guys
the mix and the mix listen folks people
get whacked in television they're not
liking anybody
over there hardly because whoever picked
picked the right crew
huh you know i remember that breakfast
with burnett in a place you know called
shutters
he called me up and i was working in
england for discovery channel at the
time he said get over here i want to
have breakfast with you
the meeting was only supposed to be like
half an hour we spent till two in the
afternoon together at shutters
never talking about shark tank about a
bunch of other stuff
and um he said look limo's gonna pick up
in the morning we're going to shoot in
the paramount
lot um anyway so i'll pick up at seven
o'clock and i said so what's this all
about he said
i'm looking for a real [ __ ] for this
new show i got called shark tank and
you're the guy
and i said okay that sounds good let's
go i didn't even know what the show's
about i just sat there in the morning
and i said to him you mean you want me
to invest my money in this stuff
it's my money that was the first thing i
remember saying to him and we never
looked back
we never looked back you know he used to
say to me in season four i'm saying hey
mark i'm getting
i'm getting all this hate mail and he
says don't go changing
don't go changing you know it's uh he's
terrific he's
he's a really fun guy to work with yeah
smart guy
i'll tell you what kevin in a world
where i don't quite understand what's
going on but i realize i'm in the
middle of a huge shift in many ways
i still periodically need the totem of
the meritocracy and i will run
towards it now shark tank's not perfect
i know it's a tv show
but at some point i am still as i know
many of your viewers are
highly enamored of somebody who sits at
home thinks of something
acts on it pushes it to the point where
they have the balls to walk down
an aquarium hallway and sell it
to a bunch of people get the money and
push it further down the road to me it's
almost the last outpost of the american
dream in some way so
i'm appreciative i know your fans are
and you play a key part in that as the
the cool pragmatist in the middle
there's a reason you're still in the
middle of the panel
i appreciate that i'll tell you after
all these years something amazing has
happened to me because
you know when they come down that hall
they're nervous as hell
it's the first time all the cameras and
lights are on them but they have to
stand while the floor director gets the
steadicam to get that shot of them
beside their product
which takes about 90 seconds and the and
you know floor director will say don't
say anything don't move
just look ahead and they're looking
right at me and i look
right back at them and i keep you know
laser focused on their eyes and i can
tell
right there after about 30 seconds
winner or loser
just from the aura just from their
ability to project their confidence
or not right there and they're standing
on the carpet i mean
it's it's remarkable and i'm not wrong
anymore
it's just the weirdest thing and i
admire their their
total guts to do that because they can
practice from the mirror for two days
that they want
but when you get there and it's the
cameras are rolling and you're there
it's a it's scary the only thing that
can throw you off is there some poor
people who come in with an
idea and they don't have the uh are
about them but the idea seems
unshoot-donnable
then there are other cats who have
nothing but they come in and they're so
smooth that guy who pitches
hairstyling and grooming and that barber
has the hots for he's on every couple
years
he always comes in i go where's the
where's the da what do you have here
brother except
you know something to trim your goatee
with but the cat is so
smooth you want to push chips in well
listen the show is a delight and as i
said if you want to see kevin and the
different guys
my man is a uh a very savvy croupier
when he sits in
on halftime report on cnbc in the
morning and
uh when he and josh brown get going well
josh brought me
he makes me laugh to begin with because
he's a deadpan killer out on the island
sitting down at his rec room
he and kevin go back and forth and it's
it's fascinating
it's good television and it's savvy
advice if you like that video
wait do you see my next one don't forget
to click right over here
and subscribe what advice would you give
an entrepreneur
that is going to stand in front of you
there
after having gone through it yourself
and watching it occur
what give me give me some tips for them
because they're asking you now i'm not
doing it on their behalf